please welcome our experts cfda designer
Christian siriano host and red carpet
fashion expert Melissa Rivers and image
architect law Rose
[Applause]
didn't even consider doing this show
until we thought that we could live up
to the institution that you and your
mother Melissa put out there I think
your mother really changed the game for
Red Carpet
designer fashion the question was born
who are you wearing hello Christian
siriano
okay speaking of you have designed so
many iconic Oscars looks I mean it's
like the Super Bowl of fashion it really
is
um I think back to seeing something I'd
never seen before in my entire life the
Billy Porter gown that you designed I'd
never seen anything
what is your approach to this particular
Super Bowl of fashion
I think I go after now I don't even
really design for anything else but the
person like I really want to really get
into like what are you promoting or what
are you going for or like what you're
feeling right now in your life like I'm
more interested in that so I think it's
just how the person really is feeling in
the moment well it's interesting that
you say that because law you are mood
driven you are iconic inspiration you
are backward Celine right now hello
thank you so much for this iconic moment
I mean I mean one of the most iconic
Oscar looks ever and one of the years
later we're still talking about it she
was ahead of her time yes but also what
you call a head turner not because she's
backwards and I'll just please say this
because it would I would be remiss if I
didn't get it use this opportunity to
tell you this your mom first of all
changed my life the first time that she
um that she mentions Zendaya she was
wearing this ungaro dress and the day
after that we got a invite to the Met
Gala for the first time
we I wouldn't exist and no matter other
stylists said we would not exist if it
was not for Joan Rivers
and honor her today let's get into some
Oscars fashion and let's start off with
some of our favorite looks of all time
Rossi well you know when they asked what
are your favorite Oscar looks of all
time as a super fan I really had to dig
deep so I thought about who are some of
my favorite actresses there's no one
more stylish than Diane Keaton and
there's one look
two more Ralph Lauren in 2004 and it was
such like a itch it was an homage almost
silent film like actors it's going a bit
Buster Keaton for sure and nobody I
couldn't think of anybody else in the
world who could pull off a look like
that and that's why I chose this Diane
Keaton look smart she's my style icon I
know I'm all for it what's next of
course I love Gwyneth Paltrow you know
she's beyond for me I think she always
tells it and I chose this Tom Ford from
2012 because it is so classic I thought
it was just structurally gorgeous in
such a moment for one of my favorite
people on the planet she is the right
one to wear this too I mean she is so
statuesque and graceful speaking of
Melissa one of your favorites is very
much in keeping with the Gwyneth
paltrows of the world Grace Kelly in
1955.
made by the famous Edith Head and one of
the reasons I love this is what do we
all say when someone shows up looking
elegant and amazing we say Grace Kelly
we always say she pulling a Grace Kelly
that's exactly right all right Christian
well who's yours well I'm going to bring
you back to 1982 when this beautiful
stunning you might know her she's really
cute
um Drew Barrymore
[Applause]
never gets old
arriving to the Oscars and she is
arriving and she's in her little faux
fur but the biggest pearls and I'm like
are those real girl and I was like Wow
and my mom you know we she's a single
working mom we didn't make a ton of
money off UT barely any it was 1982 and
I was you know a kid so she took me to
Bonnie's Wii shop and we bought it off
the rack and that was that was the look
and now it's iconic all right
I can't wait to get your hot take who
are some of your faves all my clients
I'm just kidding I'm just kidding so um
Zendaya in 2015 in the Vivian Westwood
[Applause]
this was her first time going being
invited to the Oscars but the bigger
picture of what what happened with this
dress there was a bit of controversy
controversy about her hair but what it
did is it was able to open up a global
conversation on what's appropriate for
black women's hair and where so after
that a little after that the crown Act
was
um was put into place that protects
women black women's choice to wear
braids or afros so not only it was a
great look but it really changed the
world yeah it did yeah and yeah
happened on Fashion Police ironically
and that moment did ahead of its time
were in a much different era now and
that was a catapult to a bigger better
conversation and a change and so you
know I'm very glad that that happened
too thank you my favorite pick when I
saw Michelle Williams in the 2006 Euro
Wing draft that dress that color that
architecture that detail I just thought
gosh that is my favorite Oscars dress I
ever saw and then funny enough I follow
it up with another abundant uh color
which is Gemma Chan in 2019 in this
Valentino and I love your love of color
too
[Applause]